hey guys it's Justine and guess what
we've got ourselves a pixel through here
I'm really excited about this film
because I've been such a huge fan of
previous pixel phones so when they
finally had their announcement even
though most of the things about this
phone were already leaked I will soon
have an unboxing in a full review but
this is kind of just like a first look
and sort of impressions the event was
really cool unfortunately I was not able
to make it I was so upset because I
really really wanted to go but I was
shooting something very fun which I
can't wait to share with you guys what
I've been working on it's a little
something this is the 64 gigabyte
version they also have a 128 comes in
three different colors it has four gigs
of RAM I think a lot of people were
expecting this phone to be a lot more
than what it is mostly because the
rumours everyone thought that okay those
were just rumours those are speculations
obviously that is probably true is that
going to be some sort of secret phone
that we don't know about but it turns
out most of the leaks were true and real
but for the most part I so far I'm
really liking this phone I have
mentioned before one of the things that
I do like about the pixels it's little
accent color they put on the power
buttons is so cute and so thoughtful and
it's interesting because they're always
such random color choices it feels like
it's something that you would not
normally put with this color of a phone
but the mint green on here I think it
looks beautiful so far it feels pretty
fast one of the things that I was hoping
that it would have though is facial
recognition because I do love just being
able to look at my phone pick it up and
it's just magically on but this phone
does not have that it does have fast
charged just had the fingerprint sensor
in the back which is thankfully very
nicely placed in a great location that
it was easy to access it's weird because
it's been a while since I've used the
fingerprint access because on the note 9
I was just so used to the facial
recognition and on the iPhone I use face
ID so it's weird to even do that again
because it's been a while but it's it's
pretty intuitive I mean you just sit
it's on I also like that because I like
to also add my sisters a fingerprint to
my phones and usually on face ID like
you can't do that you can only have one
face it will be interesting when they do
allow multiple faces like at this point
in my life I'm like my sister needs to
know everything that I'm doing at all
time to make sure that I'm functioning
properly I
I can't stress enough that if I don't
know what I would do without her like
she is a lifesaver she like basically
films all of my videos runs all kinds of
tasks and errands for me so I need to do
like if Jenna appreciation day again we
need to have like a Jenna Appreciation
Month because she isn't so much for me
this year like I can't even tell you so
maybe as an appreciation goal subscribe
to her channel youtube.com slash it's me
Johnny II say hi to her on Twitter at
Jenny's Eric Instagram Johnny's there
don't tell her hi and tell her that
she's the best because honestly she
really really is anyway I'm gonna go out
and take a few photos with this and I
will give you guys some photo examples
and then look for the full review very
very shortly but so far I think it's
great it's super fast really speedy so
we'll see if that holds up in the long
term as I started installing all kinds
of apps and things like that it's so
wide angle while let's go take some
pictures and I will see you guys very
soon for the full review and impressions
[Music]
so he didn't end up taking as many
photos as I'd planned on tonight to do
this quick little review for you but I
posted this picture on Twitter saying
shot on pixel 3 and I was excited
because I thought it looked good
appreciate the compliment but they said
that if you take a picture of me with
the toaster that it would still look
amazing so I appreciate it thank you if
there is a toaster that takes photos
please let me know because I would
definitely love to check it out then we
have people like this saying Apple sheep
I think you now have competition even
the previous pixel 2 is still it was
like I'm posting a picture saying that
the pixel is great we go down here and
Leon is telling me that's not a pixel 3
Brandon is saying it lacks the sharpness
of literally every pixel 3 shot so far
he's telling my face is washed this is
the tennis I like I shot this on the
freakin pixel phone I shot on the pixel
I've not even making this up like you
guys are I'm you can't even oh my gosh
oh and then someone making fun of me
cause I have a wrinkle in my cheek Oh
keep you guys kids see me but I'm like
flailing around kicking sometimes the
internet is still so shocking to me even
though I've been doing this for so so
long and that was my not pixel felon I
said I took that picture with the pixel
3 this is the pixel 3 here's the picture
portrait to see like this is I'm not
lying
Jonathan you have ruined it for everyone
I'm not trolling this is this is it I
also posted this on Instagram so we can
read through some of these comments did
you not like any of the pictures I took
took a bunch of them for me but this was
taken it was a portrait front-facing
selfie and yes i'm screen recording this
on my iphone but i don't know i'm not
sure don't judge me I'm inside a potato
me neelaveni lad whoa not an apple
product what have you done with iJustine
how is my hair flawless I don't know the
side of your hair looks cut out so it's
definitely not an iPhone I feel like
most of the portrait mode photos whether
it's on an iPhone or it's on the pixel
or it's on the note they're never going
to be perfect because it's using AI it's
not using actual glass and these are two
other photos that I took outside today
and I'm pretty surprised like you can
see around the hairline it did a really
good job I'm looking forward to testing
this out a little bit more but again I
think the photos are they're looking
pretty good it will be interesting to
see this up against the iPhone 10's
against the note 9 so I guess in the
meantime let's get rowdy in the comments
I would love to hear more about what you
guys think what do you think of these
first look photos what do you think of
iOS versus Android do I even want to
know oh my gosh I'm not sure if I'm
ready I'll see you in my next video bye
[Music]